what up space fam goes in here from
anime upper and I'm back at it again to
discuss the latest and craziest
development to the one piece story and
we got some truly insane Monumental
stuff to discuss here including
Blackbeard throwing up the Egghead
shakes vs kid and Shanks getting serious
and showing us his true power for the
first time ever it is crazy so make sure
to stay tuned for this historic
one-piece chapter if you enjoy seeing
these one piece reviews I want to keep
them coming turn the pirate king with it
and smash that like button until you see
fireworks make this the video you joined
the document by subscribing and hitting
that notification Bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one piece videos and updates and now
without further Ado let's jump into It
spoilers and all this chapter is called
the emperor red-haired Pirates and wow
it's perfect because it's such a big
chapter for Shanks and a kind of
introduction to his actual power for the
first time but first we got some
interesting stuff on Egghead we're shown
what York was doing a few hours ago and
why she went after cp02 and not just the
straw hats even though she did reach out
to her world government and was a
traitor to our guys as she explains
trouble is the world government isn't
just after Stella they want to erase me
too York says she's speaking to the four
seraphim as bear snake shark and Hawk
thus her plan is for them to deal with
anyone who gets in the way she gives
them the order to kill everyone except
her Stella and the hostages in the
basement and they agree it's pretty cool
how specific she can get with the
instructions most of us probably assume
that the orders would be more
straightforward like kill him or kill
them but here York gives more detailed
instructions so she wouldn't look like
the traitor she knew everyone would look
for a traitor when the seraphim started
running amok and she's not strong enough
to fight the others if they find out it
was her so she tells ethnic to pretend
she got York right in front of their
eyes AKA to pretend that she turned York
into stone but then she will undo the
petrification when no one is around and
it's funny and cute how a snake just
says okay and gives a thumbs up the
personality of these killing machines is
a very fun aspect to them I must say
York also goes on to tell them which
places inside the laboratory they must
not destroy and then she sends them off
to start the hunt now we're back to the
present and we see sento Maru and others
boarding a ship to escape from Egghead
this was set up last time where the
inhabitants were warned that this could
be worse than what the Garment did to
O'Hara but the really crazy part in the
Egghead section is that we see a ship
approaching and it's bearing the
Blackbeard flag which could well mean
that Blackbeard Pirates ended up beating
the hard Pirates and are now coming to
Egghead it's crazy stuff and I even
mentioned the possibility of this
happening last chapter if Kobe is on the
ship you may have GARP showing up too
before the famous incident that will
happen tomorrow takes place Egghead is
being set up to be an insane Battlefield
and perhaps even crazier than the god
Valley incident I will just mention that
there is the possibility that Blackbeard
is not actually on this trip and it
could just be some of his men like kuzan
who are given a separate Mission still
whoever it ends up being with kizero and
Saturn also coming it's gonna be insane
no doubt now that was already hype but
now we are actually moving to the more
hype section of the chapter believe it
or not we're at warland lbath in the new
world the kid pirates are confronted by
some not so fearsome looking Pirates but
they serve under their Chief red-haired
Shanks you got the captain of the puddle
Pirates saying they won't let him even
get a glimpse of Shanks you got Social
Club Captain Dentures fugar whose
Dentures fell out and princess of the
bourgeoisie Pirates shivering purulu kid
like most of us sees these guys as a
joke and wonders if they really are part
of the red hair Fleet he says we're
still in the new world right implying
that these guys seem too weak to even
survive in the new world killer though
lets them know that there are some
famous faces in there so they shouldn't
let their guard down I would love to
know what famous faces he's talking
about but alas he doesn't Point them out
kid says father or not he's not holding
back we then jump to Shanks and like the
last Shanks chapter we get a lot of
shank's time in this one and it's very
meaningful time too first he tells his
guys to have all their ships cleared out
some people are surprised but he says he
can't let him which I assume means kid
lay a finger on them the ships are
ordered to fall back again sometimes
with these speech bubbles it can be
difficult to be sure who's saying what
but we get the gist of things anyways a
bunch of pirates are sad that Shanks
their Chief is leaving already Pirates
are hugging Shanks and cling on to him
to the point where he looks straight up
annoyed at some points they really want
to give us a sense of how popular he is
and how much people love him he says it
was just a short stay here but he stayed
for too long and look this hot shot
meaning kid ran into him he says again
now make way and get your ships out of
the way this is like the Beatles Peak
Beetle Mania tried to make their way
through a crowd full of fangirls into
their car and it's fitting because it's
the same for us fans we always fan boy
and fan girl over Shanks as Shanks
boards we get a bunch of speech bubbles
from those watching him board including
quotes like why are our fleets famous
for being weak and thanks to you we have
survived and are protected by your flags
so it seems these guys are less Shanks
as elected Fleet and more just pirate
saved because Shanks protects them and
so they love him and want to return the
favor even if they aren't that strong of
course Shanks wants them to clear the
way so he can take care of kid and none
of them will get hurt the dude
definitely carries a heavy burden of a
lot of people whether he shows it or not
it's funny how he still jokes around
saying to one you better watch out for
your health rather than enemies you old
hag if she lasts and responds shut up
you Chief bastard it's humorous but
shows what Shanks is all about wanting
to help all of these people rather than
seeing what he can get from them in this
sense he's like an anti-blackbeard lucky
Roo tells him it's all right boss we'll
take care of it and Shanks responds hey
hey that's a three billion Bounty we're
talking about don't underestimate the
growth rate of the youngsters and it's
another example of bounties just not
being that big of a deal or accurate
since there's only about a billion
bounty difference between cat and Shanks
but we know it's like night and day with
these two and like I always say Luffy
should have a much higher Bounty when he
beat kaido alone then kid in law who had
to team up to beat big mom but what can
you do nothing except criticized the
world government for their inaccuracies
when it comes to bounties remember last
chapter Shanks gave them a way out they
could surrender and hand over their
world Pony glyphs but kid didn't and now
he's gonna have to face Chase's wrath
shank still wants to be fair though and
asks if it looks like their wounds from
wano have already healed usopp's dad
says kid looks fine and adds that it
looks like he's itching for a fight so
Shanks just says if that's the case it's
fine Shanks is still interested in the
Blackbeard Pirates obviously that's an
ongoing interest of his and asks if
there are any updates on Blackbeard and
is told nah but he's definitely left
Pirate Island though so again could be
him approaching Egghead that would be
crazy shank says he thought Blackbeard
would show his face at wano which is
funny for me because I like a lot of
fans thought the same so nice to see
someone reflect that sentiment even if
it never came about out and that's
probably why the red hair Pirates were
there in the first place in case
Blackbeard wanted the medal who knows
perhaps Blackbeard foresaw Shanks coming
and that's why he didn't show up anyways
back to the present Shanks is given
Intel on kid and he sees he's from South
Blue and that he's quite the
Troublemaker as we know kid has a worse
reputation than Luffy and law when it
comes to doing immoral things and that
may be a factor for Shanks doing what
he's about to do kid for his part asks
how many ships there are and is told
nine in killer adds that he sees some
faces from the wanted posters and then
we enter into it this is the big crazy
part of the chapter you gotta respect
kid's attitude and bravery if not his
results he says it doesn't matter who
he's gotta fight he'll annihilate all of
them in 10 seconds so that's the time
period it's gonna take 10 seconds that
means everything Shanks is about to do
he's gonna do in less than 10 seconds
kid begins charging his damned Punk
there is panic they notice the Canon
looking weapon and comment that ships
are getting pulled in Shanks takes
notice and to kids credit Shanks looks
very serious and worried he moves into
action saying this is bad and to spread
out the fleet to the left and the right
he tells Dorian bragi to watch his rear
we see the damage kid is about to do to
the ships and it's devastating Shanks
calls it too severe and again his face
looks very worried I love how chill
Beckman is though and just says You must
have seen a bad future there didn't you
we've always been saying that Shanks is
a hockey master or maybe I should say
monster perhaps the greatest in the
series but this gives us a sense of just
how advanced his observation hockey is
and his Future Vision in particular in
the Future Vision we see people die too
so Shanks knows he has to act quickly to
save those lives because after all they
are his people and in his view probably
his responsibility again though through
this Future Vision and Shanks even
saying Quite a feat when seeing it Oda
pays respect to kid even while everyone
present at the actual event still has no
idea what kid is capable of Shanks then
jumps all the way to kid's ship to kids
shock we can assume all the this
happened in seconds if not milliseconds
we actually see Shanks use a serious
attack with his sword Divine departure
this is what we've been waiting for for
so long for over a thousand chapters
1079 to be specific and as he's using
the attack people pass out from his
hockey alone as we're used to seeing
while kid and killer are immobilized
after the attack and are left dying
after one attack mind you and Shanks is
fine completely fine we just see his
epic serious face looking like some sort
of legendary statue this is what it
means to be a yonko right here but
honestly even more so than just the
yonko big mom lost a kid in law and big
mom delivered some hits to both of them
while kid just got taken out by one
quick hit from Shanks it was over before
it even started that's the Legendary
Power of Shanks the power that's been
hyped up for so long and it was
definitely worth the wait the kid
pirates are freaking out begging for
Shanks to not kill their boss they hand
over the road poneoglyphs but remember
Shanks warned them and gave them a
choice to avoid the fight and they
ignored the warning Shanks despite
usually being a nice guy is no pushover
when it comes to important things like
this he leaves their ship and lets Dory
and bragi Destroy what's left of the
crew and the ship after Shanks has taken
out their two strongest Fighters no
mercy and that's the way a Yanko should
be especially after giving the warning I
like the reference to the first chapter
too it was amazing as Dory and bragi say
you little runts if you point a loaded
gun at someone's Hometown be prepared to
suffer the same fate okay their attack
utterly destroys what slaps of the crew
and the ship the narrator tells us that
the kid pirate spearheaded by the 3
billion Berry Bounty useless Captain
Kidd were utterly destroyed and we just
see shanks's serious face as he's called
an absolute Powerhouse if there was any
doubt whether or not Shanks is strong by
yako standards I hope this clears it up
for everybody from the outside the dude
just took out kid a dude with a 3
billion Bounty and his crew in seconds
before they could even get an attack off
it is only because Oda gave us a view of
shanks's Future Vision that we can have
some respect for how powerful kids
attack would have been but wow as
someone who liked kid who enjoyed his
character and his Dynamic with Luffy and
everybody else it's kind of sad to see
him go but I obviously like Shanks way
more so if it serves to Hype up Shanks
I'm not even complaining this was beyond
epic and such a great way to show what
this Yak was truly capable of like I
said a historic chapter and we're so
lucky to get to witness it as it comes
out like this but to those who paid
close attention Shanks has always been
hyped up as powerful even from the
beginning if you love Shanks you don't
want to miss my hour-long video of him
telling you everything we know about the
red-haired yonko so far link to that is
on screen right now and in the
description and I'll see you there